to talk about what we mean when we say
signature combat
thanks matt now a lot has changed for us
since the first black ops game
from our development pipelines to
totally new technologies
but some things haven't changed and
after over a decade of making black ops
games we're more inspired than ever
to keep honing in on that authentic
classic black ops feel
all while taking it to new heights
now we know that to you combat is more
than just
pointing and shooting it's about how
your operator moves and weaves through
your surroundings
it's feeling the power of your weapon
how it reacts in your hands
it's the sound of bullets storming past
you the rattle and
bang of firing your weapon in cold war
we're back to plausible
authentic boots on the ground combat and
that has allowed us to not only refine
the feel of the game
but build on all the classic foundations
of black ops heads up gameplay
automated healing and grounded movement
keeping your player experience in the
front of our minds
has also inspired a fresh wave of
thinking across our creative class
and score streak system where we're
introducing features
that bring unprecedented transparency to
your planning
and cinematic wow moments to when you're
playing
now innovating systems while still
capturing that signature black ops super
smooth feel
is a notoriously tricky thing to get
just right and we put everything we have
into it for each game
this is an absolute team effort so i
brought some of my friends from the
combat team
to help tell you about our initiatives
for this game and how they've resulted
in signature combat that feels just
right
here's max porter to start us off
we've taken lessons learned from across
black ops and the entire call of duty
franchise to land on a truly
best-in-class weapon experience the gun
is almost always right in front of you
and must look great
from a gun seems down to its grime the
level of detail in black ops cold war
has never
been higher but our weapons also need to
move in a realistic manner
you'll feel it in this game whether
you're clocking from long range
or firing from the hip when we think
about a gun we think about the way it
looks the way it's going to move but a
big part of the gun's personality is the
sound that it makes it's like the bark
of the dog
we're sort of imagining all these guns
as characters
that just adds to that level of realism
and that sort of immersive quality that
is unique to call of duty
it's this multifaceted approach to how
weapons look animate and sound that
together defines the feel of cold war's
signature gun fighting experience
here's alvin with a debrief on some of
the other combat systems waiting for you
in cold war
let's talk about two of the most
significant and impactful features of
multiplayer
create a class in scorestreaks our goal
with create a class in cold war
is to empower you without making
trade-offs this year
better starts with simpler create a
class will be a slot based system
no longer governed by allocations or the
pick 10 system
you'll always boast a full class of a
primary
secondary lethal tactical
field upgrade and a set of perks field
upgrades are items placed in the world
to give your team an advantage
you can earn them solely based on time
not score
and they are the only type of game
content that works on a cooldown that
lasts
after death now wild cards are back
in this system in every class you can
pick one of four wild cards
that let you do things like load your
primary weapon with up to eight
attachments
carry up to six perks double the number
of lethals and tacticals you have
or carry three primary perks from any
mix of categories
of course a key component of create a
class
is the gunsmith
in black ops cold war there are more
optics
and attachments to unlock and configure
than ever before
every primary weapon can be customized
with 54 attachments
across eight different nodes or
attachment points with at least
six options per attach point by default
you can equip
five attachments or eight with the
gunfire wild card
for the first time gutsmith will show
you what equipping an attachment does as
a positive or negative percentage
you can now build backwards specking out
the perfect gun
for results you want to see in the field
this takes the guesswork
out of the system and helps us on our
never-ending quest
to make the most balanced call of duty
game you've ever played
there's one more thing i need to talk
about first up we've updated scorestreak
so that earned score is kept
through death this change gives all
players a chance to engage with
sportswear
one of the most visceral and fun
experiences across multiplayer's
signature comedy
if you do go on a streak and string
together multiple kills before your own
death
streak score bonuses help you learn into
those higher powered score stream teams
to prevent score streaks span each score
streak will go on a cooldown after it's
used to pace out frequency
so what score streaks are we talking
about well
your favorites are back but we've also
got a few surprises
scorestreaks in cold war can be used in
all the classic ways
to aid in taking an objective to save
your team
to break up the pace of the game with a
fun new experience
we've also tailored strategy into the
system as scorestreaks can often be
neutralized through the counter school
stream
and now i'll pass it over to sunny to
share more about our operators
and how they move in black ops cold war
elite covert powerful when you play as a
cold war operator you won't just step in
the boots of a highly trained precision
instrument
every movement will have a purpose to
increase the fidelity and feel of even
the smallest elements
modelers animators and concept artists
all work
side by side planning for every point of
contact with every gun
every stance and position every scenario
thanks to increased dynamic bone counts
we've been able to enhance the effects
of physics and gravity on what you carry
from the weight of your gear like
pouches and grenades
to the way a wallet chain or rope sways
as you sprint
your entire operator will move more
naturally than ever
here's four specific ways movement has
improved through new cutting edge
techniques in the animation and
programmatic movement
the first is sprint takeoff this is the
feature that gives your operator a
running start
you start with a little sprint and then
it slows down to normal speed
this lets you feel the momentum of like
where you're going and where you're
gonna end up
we wanted to preserve the fluidity and
fun of an operator's ability to slide
in black ops cold war when you slide you
start and end in a crouch position in a
believable way
this allows two player movement states
to function better as one
all while improving gameplay enhancing
pace footstep control also plays a big
part of the new movie system
go faster and you'll make more noise of
course we still have ninja as a perk
but ninja is no longer the only way to
keep quiet
whether or not you're crouched how loud
you get is now directly tied to how fast
you're moving
lastly we've incorporated a classic jump
with a much more natural height which
will very briefly slow you down on
landing
our goal in all of these movement
mechanics is to ensure
operators actions are not just authentic
but intuitive
when you press a button or a key you
should always feel in control of your
operator
and this system has been built to
translate your decisions into dynamic
movement more seamlessly than ever
the era of the game might be the 80s but
the characters you play will move and
shoot like the world's most highly
skilled operators
signature combat it isn't just how a gun
is shot
it's how that gun feels how it sounds
how it's designed to create a combat
experience
and combat isn't just about conflict
it's also a movement
so the fluid ways in which your
operators shift around the ao
and carry the gear you outfit them in is
just as important as the choices you
give them
choices like the overhauled creative
class system or all those attachment
possibilities in gunsmith
or the new ways you can earn and deploy
score streaks in the thick of battle
these combat initiatives work together
to deliver the most intuitive
plausible authentic boots on the ground
experience possible
and they are at the heart of black ops
cold war
now on that note i'd like to introduce
miles who's going to discuss some